tout doit disparaître près de quinze
mille jouets ont été collectés cette
année dans le cadre de l'action
organisée par ski bus depuis 1996 le
donneur c'est principalement dans les
écoles élémentaires et les écoles
maternelles avec toute une démarche
pédagogique avant des instituteurs qui
explique pourquoi il faut venir donner
vos enfants donnez un jouet qu'ils ont
aimés mais que maintenant est dépassé au
niveau de l'âge donc ça c'est une
première collecte et ensuite donc on a
aussi beaucoup de gens qui viennent
donner directement dans le bus au centre
commercial ont qui vont acheter des
jouets neufs
on a énormément de joie leurs peluches
jeux de société livres sont ensuite
redistribués à dix associations
caritatives locales jouait deux premiers
âges poupée dvd ces associations font le
plein avant de redonner elle même aux
plus défavorisés au sein de
l'association boucher coeur 150 enfants
de 0 à 14 ans bénéficient de cette
collecte de jouets n'a beaucoup de
familles monoparentales de messieurs
tout seul ou de gens avec des petites
retraites
et puis même des couples qui ont un
petit salaire on prend des jouets pour
les petits parce qu'évidemment on a des
enfants de 0 à 13 ans mais là on va
prendre côté pour les plus petits cette
année encore et malgré la crise les plus
démunis pourront avoir un véritable noël